the British pub is legendary the world
over the local watering hole where
people gather sometimes daily to enjoy a
frosty pint
when coronavirus restrictions went into
place across england that way of life
was put on hold except in one part of
East London where a local Brewer an
American came up with a solution that's
driving his customers mad with gratitude
empty as tyub has the story pulling
pints is second nature to Peter Brown
but never before like this the
Massachusetts born owner of the Forest
Road brewery had to shut most of his
business because of the coronavirus
lockdown with no clients and kegs
collecting dust he dreamed up the
tactical beer response unit in which he
Braves the mean streets of East London
to bring socially distant pints of lager
to people longing for the pub pong your
pints are here
like any good barman he offers advice on
his beers and has yet another satisfied
customer
it's probably about the best thing that
could possibly get delivered Brown has
been brewing beer in East London for
over a decade and business was booming
earlier this year he flew to the US to
buy equipment to expand so you're
getting a brew kit from California to
bring here to make your beer and then
the credit viruses and then the corona
virus in that boom across Britain more
than 60,000 pubs have been shuttered
since March but for so many the billion
dollar industry isn't about serving
drinks it's about being able to come
together as a community new government
guidelines have seen some pubs turned to
selling household essentials instead
anything from produce - you guessed it
toilet paper being the hub of the
community we've got to got to stay open
we've got to keep functioning somewhere
but the weather's been so nice - isn't
it James Fitzgerald's manages the
Duchess in West London even selling
takeout business is down over 60% habits
will change and people have gotten used
to you know staying at home watching TV
but I reckon it's the heart to the heart
of Richard's society he's the part so of
course people are pining for that they
want
to get back to that pubs aren't likely
to reopen again until July except until
then those pining for a pint we'll have
to look no further than Pete's tactical
beer response unit to fill the void it
represents more than what's in the glass
it takes you to the time where you're
with your pals and things are normal and
you're trying to keep that alive one
pint at a time one plenty of time we're
trying to do trying to bring the pub to
the people CBS this morning Saturday in
Thea's Hiab London and the properly
poured pint Jeff is I think we both know
very important very important and we
can't wait to share again together
that's here right Dana